so what's going on with your boyfriend  Oh ever since my boyfriend left for work  in Antarctica he's been wanting to have  dirty talk  you mean phone sex no well yeah but  dirty so you guys look so far apart now  you have to keep it sexy yeah but I  don't know how just say all the kinkiest  things you can think of hey really go  for it  oh my God he's calling um uh yeah you  stay here  why hello hi sugar tits  he called me this I think he's trying at  home sex call him something sexy back hi  you uh so what are you wearing  he means underwear  of course fruit of a blue fruit of that  no huh jeez Victoria's Secret  oh yeah that's hot I'm going to touch  myself me too  oh my god nice nice nice yeah talk dirty  to me you dirty just go for it I want to  look your face while you're on a  conference call  hey guys thanks for watching my video  make sure you subscribe